es könnte tatsächlich ein neuer
zwergplanet seien die rede ist von dem
fehler 30 kilometer großen himmelskörper
hügel der sich im asteroidengürtel also
zwischen den planeten bahnen von mars
und jupiter befindet laut einer neuen
studie erfüllte gehe also alle kriterien
eines zwergplaneten doch dabei hat er
weitere ganz besondere charakteristika
die forschungsteams weltweit überraschen
und das hat konsequenzen für unsere
bisherige sicht auf andere noch nicht
vermessen objekte in unserem
sonnensystem gibt es also noch viel mehr
zwergplaneten klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen bisher
sind es nur fünf himmelskörper im
sonnensystem die laut der
internationalen astronomischen union iau
als zwergplaneten gelten dabei handelt
es sich um die folgenden fünf eris romer
pluto und mac mac als trans neptun ische
objekte also hinter dem neptun hinzu
kommt er es im asteroidengürtel
womöglich gibt es jenseits des neptuns
aber noch weitere zwergplaneten doch
derzeit sind das nur potenzielle
kandidaten das problem dabei die
derzeitigen teleskope sind zu schwach um
bei ihnen eines der vier entscheidenden
charakteristika der zwerg planeten
nachzuweisen
die kugelige form in der fachsprache ist
in diesem kontext von dem so genannten
hydrostatischen gleichgewicht gerät
das bedeutet dass die himmelskörper
durch ihre eigene schwerkraft eine form
haben die fast perfekt rund ist oder
anders formuliert zwergplaneten haben
sich unter ihrem eigenen gewicht zu
einer kugel verdichtet doch wie klein
kann ein himmelskörper sein und doch
ausreichend schwerkraft besitzen um
solch eine kugelform vorzuweisen eine
frage die bislang unbeantwortet blieb
diskutiert wurde immer wieder ob der 950
kilometer große cs der kleinstmögliche
zwergplanet ist oder ob auch kleinere
himmelskörper kugelig grund sein könnten
neben der kollegen form gibt es aber
noch weitere drei kriterien die ein
himmelskörper erfüllen muss um als
zwergplanet zu gelten
dafür muss er die sonne umkreisen dabei
aber kein mond sein
das führte kriterium steht immer wieder
zur diskussion hierbei geht es darum
dass zwergplaneten ihre umlaufbahn nicht
von anderen himmelskörpern
freigeräumt haben genau das ist auch die
große streitfrage bei bluetooth kurs
dazu pluta hatte im sommer 2006 seinen
status als planet verloren doch genau
das wird von vielen kritikern bezweifelt
unter anderem vom nasa chef jim brittens
sein er hatte noch vor kurzem bei
twitter erklärt dass pluto für ihn
weiterhin als planet gelte im hotel der
nasa administrator believe pluto ist
planet ja und er hat damit nicht ganz
unrecht weil die kriterien für planeten
zumindest eben umstritten sind
ein französisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt den asteoriden hügel er genauer
ins visier genommen es handelt sich um
einen 430 km großen bisher als
asteroiden eingestuften himmelskörpers
der als das viertgrößte objekt im
asteroidengürtel zählt dieser
himmelskörper wurde schon vor 170 jahren
entdeckt doch seine analyse ist eine
echte premiere
die mit dem sphere instrument am very
large telescope der europäischen
südsternwarte in chile gelangen dazu der
astronom pia vernazza wie er konnte noch
nie mit gemüsen hohe auflösung
beobachtet werden um details seine
oberfläche zu zeigen oder seine form und
größe näher zu bestimmen die experten
und expertinnen waren zuvor also völlig
ahnungslos wie man sich die form von
hygiene vor zu stellen hat doch die
auswertung der beobachtungen enthüllen
das überraschende ergebnis denn der
himmelskörper ist fast perfekt kugel
geformt und das obwohl er deutlich
kleiner ist als alle anderen asteroiden
denn gestalt deutlich unförmiger ist
pallas oder fester sind hier gute
beispiele der neuen analyse zufolge
lässt sich über gut mit dem
zwergplaneten ceres vergleichen nicht
nur seine zusammensetzung und dichte
scheint sehr es ähnlich zu sein sondern
auch seine glatte oberfläche dazu
schreibt das autorenteam in der neuen
studie
unsere analysen zeigen dass die
großräumige topographie von jeher von
csr große einschlag strecken scheinen
auf seiner oberfläche zu fehlen doch vor
allem die nahezu perfekt kugel geformt
überrascht das französische forschungs
team den hügel zeigt damit dass seine
vergleichsweise geringe größe und
schwerkraft ausreichen um solch eine
sphärisch geformten oberfläche
vorzuweisen
für die fachleute ist klar dass sie wie
er somit als zwergplanet gilt dank
dieser bilder kann lydia als zwergplanet
rick klassifiziert werden
bisher kleinste im sonnensystem doch
eine grosse frage bleibt wie kommt solch
ein kleiner zwergplanet an seine perfekt
kugelige form währenddessen andere
deutlich größere asteoriden eine
unregelmäßige form aufweisen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vermuten dass eine
krasse kollision zu dieser
überraschenden form führte
möglicherweise kam es vor zwei
milliarden jahren dazu dass ein rund 100
kilometer große asteroid frontal mit
einem größeren vorläufer objekt
zusammengestoßen ist beide objekte
wurden bei diesem riesen crash zerstört
doch aus den trümmern bildete sich wie
er also aus den trümmern also als
kleinen brocken dazu cavusevic der an
der studie beteiligt war
eine solche kollision zwischen zwei
großen treffern im aktuellen gürtel ist
in den letzten drei bis vier milliarden
einzigartig die komponenten von hügli er
also diese brötchen brocken verhielten
sich möglicherweise beim zusammenballen
wie eine flüssigkeit so dass die
schwerkraft sie zu einer fast perfekten
kugelform konnte diese neuen
erkenntnisse lassen vermuten dass es
jenseits des neptuns viele weitere
planeten geben könnte
diese könnten ähnlich klein sein wie er
mit seinen rund 400 kilometern das
forschungsteam schließt nicht aus dass
auch far out dazu gehören könnte ein
objekt das erst im vergangenen jahr 2018
aufgespürt wurde und an durchmesser von
500 kilometern hat falls dem so ist
würde es sich hierbei um den bislang
fernsten zwerg planeten handeln den wir
kennen doch auch hier macht uns die
auflösung der derzeitigen teleskope
einen strich durch die rechnung wenn sie
reichten bislang noch nicht aus um die
form von objekten jenseits des neptuns
zu zeigen
größenvergleich im sonnensystem
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
abonnieren
aber kanal bis dann bleib dran